minha preparação física para um
campeonato internacional de boxe hein eu
aqueço com esse exercício que parece de
parto humanizado depois cinco minutos na
esteira depois vem 10 segundos de
desgraça de escada de agilidade 10
segundos de descanso depois eu boto os
cavalos Romano Imaginário para correr dá
para ver que eu amo com essa cara de
Kiko aí Bam depois mais escada meu Deus
para que tanta escada meu Deus não tem
rampa não cadê a sensibilidade eu já
querendo morrer arrependido só meter em
confusão Então vai jogar bola no chão
Bora jumento velho depois as pernas já
morta pula para lá e para cá sozinho
pingando em câmera lenta ali passando na
frente do pics Bad Caso vocês querem
apostar em mim aqui eu já arrependi de
tudo isso essa desgraça e vem o rolinho
para fazer o abdômen eu odeio ele só me
botar o jumento pra correr de novo vai
se meter confusão depois exercício terra
e repete tudo de novo cada exercício com
10 segundos de descanso tomada tome bola
aqui eu já sabia o exercício que vinha
depois se o diabo amasso o pão é com
esse rola depois para recuperar os
músculos banheira de gelo os ovos sobe
tanto que quase vira amígdala
chapeuzinho pra não necrosa as orelhas e
eu fico 10 minutinhos aí dentro
refletindo que o pics Patch é o único
apoiador fora minhas próprias marcas
tamo junto picsmat